(curious music)
- [Narrator] When Egypt's
Ministry of Health
issues its annual warning to
stay away from a dangerous
local delicacy called feseekh,
you'd think people would comply.
But for many, the risk
is worth the reward.
(curious music)
If prepared poorly,
feseekh can lead to
poisoning or even death.
Luckily, Ibrahim Shaheen
has been carefully preparing
this unique dish for decades.
- [Narrator] Feseekh dates back to days
when Egyptian pharaohs ruled the land.
Each spring, the Nile River would recede
and the fish covered in sea
salt and sand were left behind
to rot on its shores.
(curious music)
- [Narrator] Today it is
prepared a little differently.
The mullet fish are carefully
cleaned and sprayed with salt.
They're then placed in
sterilized vats and left to cure
for up to 25 days.
And when it's ready to
eat, the taste is ...
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] But, despite its smell,
the fermented fish has become
a staple of Egyptian culture
and Ibrahim Shaheen is
proud to carry on making
this traditional dish
safe for all to enjoy.
(upbeat music)